he's out there obviously provoking
Muslims definitely why did you come here
today
Quran which I'm gonna burn down
his nickname is the Quran burner but no
matter what you do you try to extinguish
the light of Allah Allah will perfect
his life
I'm defending my country from becoming
how
by burning someone's book no brother
Eddie there was a rally against him
that's good and it was non-muslims who
showed up the people of Norway the
youngsters non-muslims so why are you
against this then we respect religion
and freedom it's not freedom to burn the
corner
[Applause]
let me into my face
and his final message
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the beach house
your host and we're going to be talking
about this book that's been sent down as
a guidance to Mankind and you got
somebody burning it and we got the man
himself who confronted the guy who's
trying to burn the Quran not knowing
that it's a book That's supposed to be
read understood and lived by and it's a
guidance for him and the whole world and
you actually
brother Eddie the Deeds show who who
knew for defending the Deen of Allah
you'd come on The Dean show that's crazy
that is crazy you know
even to bring up that person it's such a
traumatic thing to think about but
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah I'm so happy
to be here such a pleasure thank you so
much for having me I really appreciate
you welcome nice having you my brother
thank you thank you thank you so we
started off with I mean the Quran
verbatim word of God Almighty sent down
for all of mankind it's a book that if
you look at it compiled over 23 years
it's a living Miracle embryo in the
Quran cannot be based on scientific
knowledge in the seventh seventh century
foreign
could not have known these facts about
human development in the 7th Century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century these facts could
only have been revealed to Muhammad by
the one no one who knows all about us
for anyone who sincere puts it to the
test not only the scientific Miracles
the prophecies the authenticity it's
like no other book in the world and if
anyone takes a sincere humble approach
to it they will see that this is the
blueprint for life now you've got
somebody trying to burn the book and you
actually you went and met with this
Quran burner yes that's literally you
know uh brother Eddie one of the things
that human beings crave is importance
you know and how we choose to go about
achieving that importance is what
defines us and determines how our
character and how we act upon you know
look at the life of the Prophet Muhammad
look look at how he was gained
importance and Garnet importance he was
known as
he that's what you know people
understood him as the most honest most
trustworthy most truthful person there
was okay
this person's nickname is the Quran
burner like think look at the look at
the difference over here and it's just
so sad because you want to talk sense
into a person and you want to talk to
them like hey okay look
you don't want to be a Muslim no problem
you might not even agree with what the
Quran is saying that's another problem
no worries but you don't have to hurt or
harm someone you don't gotta you know
make someone feel that way and the
argument on his end is like I don't care
about your feelings it's feelings not
not it's it's facts not feelings but I'm
like the fact is that you're hurting
someone's feelings and the prophet
Muhammad if anyone could take any type
of you know advice or guidance or
something non-muslim someone sincere out
there is that the prophet Muhammad was
sent to perfect our manners our
character so the moment you start doing
things that are out of character out of
manners out of the way that he was sent
to teach us how to act you're doing
something wrong Muslim or not Muslim
you're you're behaving in a manner
that's very animalistic and may Allah
guide him honestly I mean we want the
best for him for all of mankind I mean
so you're there what was your impression
what was your analyzation of the man
there that now people are seeing he's
out there obviously provoking Muslims
definitely and what what is your
take on it when you got to spend some
time with it is he mentally there is he
sounded what he's doing that's a very
reasonable question to ask Eddie because
when you think about it right like only
a person deluded the range would do and
behave in a certain manner like that
right he's a grandpa and you know what
part of me feels actually very upset and
guilty on how I spoke to him to some
degree because he's my Elder and I was
conflicted between him you know when he
would say something hurtful towards
Allah and his messenger it you know it
upsets you you know but you know
professionally I'm also a school teacher
you know not many know that but I teach
in the Department of Education in New
York City
acceptance you know my character is what
gives the dawah you know but it's like
that student who provokes who who pokes
and pokes and pokes and provokes and
when the other student retaliates out of
being finally frustrated
the teacher sees the kid who retaliated
but not the person poking the whole time
and the person was poking the whole time
you see I didn't do this person this
quick so that's what this guy wants he
wants a reaction
from Muslims from people to behave in a
violent and angry I mean like I was I
was kind of low-key roasting him I'm not
proud of how I did it but I just
couldn't help myself but you know people
who will be physically violent with him
or something like that please don't
behave that way that's not how to no we
don't Advocate that absolutely not
absolutely not and honestly we were
trying to have an intellectual
conversation with them so going back to
his mental state he seems like he has
his beliefs and opinions already and I
don't think it's him I think it's his
teachers because when I was asking him
parts of hey you know where did you
learn this from he would say oh I
learned this in the Quran I learned this
from the tafseed I learned this from uh
you know the the sahib I said listen bro
like when you are learning something as
a teacher
I can't just give you a book of
pre-algebra excuse me pre-algebra or
some type of calculus book and just say
good luck you know you need a teacher
you need an instructor you need someone
to guide you through it to help you and
that's the best of creation Muhammad
that's what we understand him to be he
taught us he every verse of Revelation
has a time and date and we understand
its context you know what else could you
want you know what an amazing teacher so
his teachers have corrupted him and the
corruption in the heart and may Allah
soften his heart and guide him he's a
grandpa you know I don't want his
grandchildren to be seeing this and
being raised on this may Allah guide him
seriously yeah what kind of Legacy what
are you leaving behind one of hate
intolerance
and I'm sure the brothers there probably
tried to invite him into the much into
the future Masjid there let's sit let's
talk let's reason together absolutely
absolute 1000 man and and and that's all
we want that's all we want we want to
talk to you like hey okay if you're not
about this what is the issue that you're
having with it let's sit down with some
of our best Scholars and if I don't know
the answer for it let's get you the help
for it but brother Eddie if I have to
say this just from you know from my
experience with this brother like we try
to see the good in everyone you know the
problem I haven't saw some said that the
the uh the strongest right like a
stronger believer a strong believer is
better than a weak one you know but
there's good in both you know it would
be sad and upsetting of me to look at
any human being and just look at them
with the eye of uh you know because
that's how you give dollar to anyone and
I know you're working on the dean Center
and I'm sorry I have to plug it in I'm
sorry brother Eddie I'm sorry I have to
plug it in
[Music]
yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
[Music]
[Applause]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened in basically is
far further south from the other other
big massages and everyone I know a lot
of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
the center this Center is much needed
for this area and the idea of this
Center is needed for the whole stick
because we don't have anything like that
in the whole state that was censor where
it's going to basically nurture and
basically educate and it's gonna
basically spread Islam
an incredible initiative by the way
right
revolutionizing and I went there because
of Islam net which is a you know amazing
organization who's doing a dollar Center
over there project I mean I mean I mean
and it's nothing but love from you guys
as well too but you guys are going to be
in the south of of of of the United
States where there's a ton of
islamophobia hate misconceptions like
the dean Center will be in the most
perfect position mashallah to give dawah
to America because through Florida and
through that area around the highway and
the positioning of it Allah has just
blessed so may Allah bless that project
and all the projects as well that's what
we want we want to invite him towards
Islam and more than anything we wanted
to you know dispel these myths that he
has in his mind because we want him to
come to Islam and and if and not from
the perspective of just being a Muslim
but like you know it's not right to have
someone's rights stripped away from them
you know and tell them hey you can't
wear the hijab you can't cover up up you
can't behave or dress a specific way
because of your beliefs and values tell
me this uh yeah we know this is
something that's abhorrent and it's
provocative and do you have any because
I feel like if pressure was put on him
to stop he'd probably stop is the
we don't see much of this did you see
the media coming out the mainstream
media to cover this I mean and then the
reaction from the locals there how has
that been like because we don't we don't
hear about this here absolutely because
what happens is you know a lot of times
when the pressure from the media kicks
in now some people go you know back into
their hole but yeah if and you will
usually see this the hypocrisy the
double standards imagine like a Muslim
is out there burning the Quran all
mainstream media will be covering it you
know in his home they'll be so do we see
this kind of thing was burning a Bible
or something like that okay so one thing
that we have to remember about Norway
Norway is second generation atheists at
this point right and what's really
interesting about that and I didn't
understand what that meant because the
brothers at over there in Slam name
Allah bless them explain what what what
that meant but when I saw it in action
is when I was just like oh that's what
they mean so it's the parents and then
their children have now have children
and they're also atheists and now
they're raising their children upon
atheism right and the great work that
not just what they're doing but all the
doll organizations in Norway what
they're doing is that they're giving
dawa and I like to tell people brother
Eddie and Dr Sabio said this very
beautifully uh in the the the the fun in
the dinner that we had right that you
know someone asks how do you give dawa
how do you just like do you just turn it
on is there a flick as their butt and
like you know like how
the answer is simple enough like you
don't ask like how do I be like you know
a husband every day or a son every day
that you just are you know the best form
of dawa is communicating with people and
living that having that one-to-one
experience and when a person can feel
and have that relive that experience
that wow like my actual
interaction with the Muslim has been so
positive anything that I've ever had has
been negative about it you know and our
goal is to provide that opportunity for
everyone to have so
um going back to your question which I
forgot which it was because I went on
the right media how is the media so and
the culture the people there perfect are
they putting pressure on him so Norway's
second year atheist at this point right
so they hide behind this idea of freedom
of speech law okay so there's a law that
prevents them from asking freedom speech
now when I went there you know look I
one thing I'm known for brother Eddie is
I get gritty I ask the tough questions I
go and ask those provoking type of
questions to people so I interviewed
cops and that's going to be that's also
over there as well too so you'll see how
cops were and their feelings of it you
know because some cops are just doing
their job and this person the Quran
burner is technically protected under
that law of freedom of speech and I
asked them I said hey this person is
burning a book do you not stop him
they said the only way we'll stop him
and check this out brother I mean this
is like the the important part that
everyone needs to really mind be mindful
of they said the only way we're going to
stop him is if
he is harming a tree
if that Quran now is setting fire to a
tree or it's about a harm a building is
this one of the countries that you have
people who deny the Holocaust or they
say anything against you know a certain
group of people they'll go to jail to
get locked up is this one of the
countries I know many countries in
Europe are like that you go to jail if
you're just denying a certain event yeah
subhanallah now very sad event in
history and you deny it and now you go
to jail yeah so here it seems like
people hide conveniently behind this
freedom of speech yeah right but we've
seen how that go with certain events
that have happened here you talk about
it you get a strike you get canceled you
can't bring up things but absolutely you
know it seems like it's just a
convenient card to play it looks and you
know what that's a part of the media
representation as well too and one thing
that excites me about the video that
I've posted at this point is that that
video conveys how upset the people of
Norway are they don't like him okay so
that's good that's a good thing brother
Eddie there was a rally against him
that's good and it was non-muslims who
showed up we commend you people of way
that's it more people need to stand up
like that more people definitely yeah
yes definitely the people of Norway the
youngsters non-muslims so so in this
video of mine that you see I'm I am
asking basically the question is do
Norwegians or do not does Norway hate
Muslims and it's the Quran burner
protest
and let me tell you about that Eddie
there's non-muslims there and they are
absolutely against what he stands for
why are you against this then we respect
religion and freedom okay why are you
against you you're not a Muslim it's not
okay do you like this to support them
yeah they're stupid it's not
freedom to burn the corner yes not
Freedom exactly and there's even cops
there who are absolute against what it
says unfortunately the law of Norway he
hides behind right like when I asked him
very like straight up straightforward
because he kept on accusing Muslims in
that video of dualism and being someone
to your face but really being someone
behind your back right by the law he's
not allowed to say he hates A specific
group right because then you're
officially you know indicting yourself
almost and saying that I'm a hate
preacher but you burn in the book
basically but I know I know I know it's
a thin line it's it's a very blurry line
because then I asked the question if I
speak about your mother or something
like that why would that upset you and
we know there's a blurred line of
understanding that like nah like there's
certain lines you don't cross and you
know someone's getting upset like just
chill just stop teasing but you could
tell he doesn't care you know he when
the cameras turn on brother Eddie he
becomes a different person I personally
believe he might be possessed I'm being
serious you know gin possessions there's
certain Jin and shayathin out there that
are there to describe you know from this
authentic at least about about
distracting us from our Salah you know
causing fights between husband and wife
Jin and shayathin have Specialties and
there's certain that cause you to drift
away and further away and steer you away
from Allah so I don't put it past anyone
you know
is over there but when the cameras turn
on Eddie brother he is just a different
person and stuff like that so
the average Norwegian people they do not
like him they don't stand for him but
the average Norwegian is uneducated
about Islam so yes they came out to
support us for the sake of supporting us
right because they don't like the fact
you know that someone is being harmed I
like that but they're also not educated
because I also first ask him what do you
know about Islam what do you know about
Islam
things I have learned from school and
stuff and I don't really know what to
say uh what do you guys know about Islam
not much nothing not much I'm not sure
what do you know about Islam
I think that face says it all you can't
take it with you when you go or you
can't take this with you when you go and
you can't take this with you when you go
brothers and sisters we're all going to
depart from this life and all of our
material possessions to our money will
stay behind but your reoccurring
investment in the dean Center will
continue to grow even when you leave
this light so go ahead and make that
reoccurring investment in a Masjid Mega
dollar Center that will benefit you in
this life and in the next click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of you
and that's where they would struggle
right and they have Muslim Friends by
the way they do but sometimes those
Muslim friends might not be on the dean
themselves and they they need to
understand that they need to educate
them and be friends with them that's an
opportunity from Allah and that's why
this is really important for this uh
Masjid Islamic dawah Center Educational
Center this Islam Network they're doing
this is so important to establish that
so these people can get educated and
then they're going to even support more
inshallah you got the the Abu jahl's
that turn into Abu talibs even if they
don't accept uh Islam so because they
see really what Islam is about tell me
this uh his car actually flipped didn't
it
yes yes and uh what was uh says so when
we all found out about his car flipping
around for the idea I want to explain to
you like
I think that everyone obviously look
nobody wants to see anyone get hurt you
know yeah but this dude is such a clown
like I'm serious like this dude is doing
all that it's like if you ever see those
YouTube videos I call Instant Karma
videos like he his needs to make a
that's a good point Instant Karma video
you ever see you know what I'm talking
about right like this Instagram he
literally needs to be in the next one so
shout out any in Chicago videos out
there you guys need to plug him in that
he's holding burning a Quran and the
next one he is literally in that same
rally he burned the Quran in front of a
mosque like look how intimidating this
person's trying to be he came burned the
Quran in front of the mosque imagine
coming to jumwa with your family with
your loved ones you have beautiful
children by the way brother Eddie I know
you don't show them again
you have one of the greatest mashallah
Champs who runs the entire thing in may
Allah brings you strength with your
children and make them the coolest of
your eyes I mean and um you know it's
it's a blessing they're a blessings
but but man you go there with your
family
you want to go and pray listen to the
you know me and my children we go to the
deli afterwards and you know across the
street from the Masjid
imagine that's coming out of there
and we see this dude in a military
outfit man like let's be trying to
intimidate you with this military truck
and he has like of the Quran and he's
waiting for you to come out
drenched drenched
in kerosene
so it burns better look at the
premeditated nature of this is this
freedom of speech or is this some type
of hatred in your heart it reminds me of
when they were trying to burn Ibrahim
they said we're not just gonna light the
oil or the fire uh no we're gonna lie
for days right just like uh the fire
we're gonna burn the fire for days the
same way Pharaoh wanted to burn that the
lady and the family and the children and
the oil he didn't just burn them boil
the oil he boiled it for days right he's
he's he's soaking it marinating it like
a chicken or a turkey on Thanksgiving
this dude think about it may not guide
him I mean
marinating it in kerosene and then he
brings it soaked up and lights it on
fire and you are with your children my
daughter would have to see that your
children have to see that well they know
Jiu Jitsu samashallah they might tackle
him I learned to take down yesterday
I'm so high brother Eddie I'm so high
mashallah you're an excellent teacher by
the way thank you but you know you don't
want to see that you don't want to
encounter that so all of a sudden they
come out this dude is burning the Quran
and then the people getting upset at him
they're using language as foul obviously
because they're upset obviously
understandably so but may Allah forgive
them as well
and they chase him out of there like in
like a coward Grandpa he just runs away
so while he's running away driving away
and all that sort of stuff the people
that decide to tail him a little bit a
little GTA action brother Eddie and then
the next thing she told this dude I
shouldn't be laughing at this level his
car like comes off the the you know the
the highway and the Instant Karma kicks
in and it just flips over but
alhamdulillah he's okay you know for the
most part Allah gave him another
opportunity to soften his heart and
accept Islam and to guide him to a
straight path you know imagine his
platform that he has right now and
imagine if Allah really guided his heart
and he accepted Islam
like imagine the lives he could change
and impact by Allah's permission you
know imagine but it's truly this that's
blind and unless Allah opens it and
guides you it won't happen and people
can take that to the next level if
they're a Christian or of other Faith
Jewish and you're married you're coming
out of the synagogue you're coming out
of the church and you've got somebody in
front of you doing what you just
described imagine that the reaction how
would you feel you know some people most
of them must not be in Restraint you
know you got some of these people you
know would go to a whole nother level
you know what I mean but Muslims are
really showing uh constraint they should
know no violence and stuff so uh this is
very sad to see hopefully uh go ahead
and one thing brother Eddie you know if
this was happening to a Bible if this
was happening to a Torah I would be
equally as upset I want to make that
clear and I think you would be as well
too it all Muslim should be and let me
make it exactly absolutely and one thing
for sure and this brings up another
topic you know I don't know I don't know
why these situations always attract back
to my life but a year ago from this
point at brother Eddie
um you know there was right there in
downtown Chicago you know where The Bean
Is Right downtown Chicago there's these
Hebrew Israelites that are out there you
know downtown Chicago and they have like
their whole like hate speech stuff going
on on the microphones and that and they
had their cameras there too and they
have like a bunch of writing on the
floor if you ever call and come across
them you know what I'm talking about
um and I'm listening to them and they're
going on and on and on and they had the
Bible on the floor
and I saw the Bible on the floor and I
literally brother Eddie went and
objected to that I said hey
don't put your book on the floor like
that I'm telling the Hebrew Israelites
the book that they love how it should be
respected then
my eyes go straight towards the Quran on
the floor next to it and I said oh hell
no I'm definitely not going to tolerate
this
so I'd go and grab the Quran and upon
that they try to stomp on my hand stomp
on my head right okay this is what
people don't realize stop on my head and
then now I'm playing with them I said
okay listen listen listen do your Hebrew
Israelite thing you want to tell people
say call us Ishmael all that you want to
do Bismillah do that
but let me take this book off your hands
don't treat it like this you want to
treat your don't I take the Bible off
your hands too I'll be honest with you
but don't treat this book like that
right so what happens is I started
ducking and trying to protect it and
they start stomping and pushing me off
of it this is downtown Chicago and this
is where this viral video just goes up
for like 40 seconds my phone was dead
all I could do helpless by myself
against 12 goons you've seen them travel
in packs
and at this point they're intimidating
me to have the camera from them on me
right now and they're just looking at
each other and they start stomping on
the Quran
this is what they start doing
and I think when I met you at Ikea last
year I spoke to you briefly about this
maybe as well too and I try to stop that
and all that and they knew that was my
trigger this is your Quran and fling it
across the street and I get excited why
alhamdulillah okay whatever I'm picking
up the Quran I got what I wanted I got
the Quran off of them that was enough
they came and they pushed me out
snatched it back from me and did the
same thing again helpless I felt like
the foam on the sea nothing I could do
went back actually recently and they
weren't saying anything this time
alhamdulillah but you know we can't
condone this type of behavior and the
reason I share that with you is because
of the Bible we shouldn't condone
anything anything against our Christian
brothers and sisters our Jewish brothers
and sisters if there's some harm against
them that's that's incorrect like for
example brother Eddie I'm sorry for
being so long-winded but
in France we know there's a hijab Ben we
all know that right I think I think
that's pretty common news Okay in school
but did you know that they've also
banned Sikhs from wearing their turbans
that's not right either you do you know
that they've also banned
um a Christians from wearing their cross
to represent their faith that's all
right either you see when when Muslims
in France in fact this is what the
average person doesn't know and this is
the thing brother when we only fight for
our own cause rather than the rights and
establishing the law of right and Huck
on land how everyone deserves like and
look at Medina Medina wasn't that way
you're allowed to represent your own
faith you know people try to like you
know there was Jews Christians and
Muslims living in Medina alhamdulillah
we're allowed to we can live we're
living together it could be in harmony
alhamdulillah but don't oppress us don't
oppress us you're Banning the hijabs and
those things as well too everyone has
the right to have expression of their
religion and so what they're doing the
Muslims need to be against not just that
but everyone uh uh Injustice to one to
one is Injustice to all and we need to
make sure we take care of that yeah
absolutely what was it in short that had
you get to where you are today that
you're so passionate about Islam you got
so many religions out there man-made
religions and
and people get kind of turned away
because they're like they're all the
same and so what convinced you 100
because you weren't always practicing
and some people can be like okay you
were just born in the Muslim family but
just like myself you know I went I
looked into all the different religions
and Islam without a doubt you know if
someone's sincere they take an
analytical scientific approach they'll
see that this is indeed from the crater
all this other stuff is man-made so what
did it for you about Islam that you're
here today with us brother Eddie you
know Allah has to allow certain things
to happen in our lives for us to mature
and ripen to where he wants us to be and
when we go through these tests and
difficulties Allah uses those as
opportunities to refine us as human
beings our character our morals our
values
you know I was going through a lot
of depression and sadness and anxiety
and I was actually just dealing with a
ton of depression and it was over
subhanallah a relationship that I was in
that I had broken up from and it had
broken me down to the core that I went
down back to the same lifestyle that I
was living to and it just didn't do it
for me anymore and I knew after trying
to commit you know harm to myself one
day I don't say those words might get
demonetized I mean uh and banned or
whatever but after you know trying to
harm myself I called out to the Creator
before doing it in the shower but Eddie
and I was just like if there is
something
take me out of this right and guide me
through this whoever whatever I don't
know
and if not then let this be my last
moment right now and I don't want to do
this anymore
I was able to get out of that bathroom
and I knew that there was something
bigger deeper something Beyond us
something that's metaphysical and as you
can see I studied multiple religions I
this is from the Gita the Sanskrit the
Hindu scripture I have some things in
Hebrew I'm not trying to show sins but
like you know I have some things but I
was I studied other religions other
faiths you know
um Buddhism you're going to them but so
you were really searching I was really
searching brother Eddie I was really
searching about Allah's permission I was
really searching I was searching for
what it was even though Islam was right
under your nose right under my nose I
experienced everything because Islam is
the last thing I thought of because I
viewed Islam to be backwards without
being full respect with all due respect
you know and I think that this is for
another podcast but I I arrived to New
York from from Pakistan on September 10
2001 hours before 9 11. so I had I
literally was raised in 9 11. I did not
like Islam there's a reason I am the way
I am right now and you know I think
that's same for another podcast we have
a lot to do but for in Long in long
story short you know I knew that there
was something else out there and the
Tranquility that no other book but the
Quran could give me no other book no
other book brother Eddie the Quran was
the only book that gave me that
Tranquility I tried to serve my desires
I made my nuffs as my Lord and brother
Eddie it rejected me
I made these tattoos as my lord for
happiness it rejected me I used the the
drugs the alcohol as a way to
it rejected me I was done the women it
rejected me I needed something else I
looked I looked I looked I looked
nothing made sense it was either like
some parts made sense but then this part
was just like ah what's that all about
and then the effect that I had around my
heart it didn't do anything but when I
finally by Allah's permission stumbled
upon the Quran I just found myself
getting lost in the Quran I downloaded
the app the English Quran app and you
know how like your phone times out after
a certain time when it's idle like you
know after like four minutes five
minutes whatever
I would read the Quran and I would just
get stuck on one verse in English of
course because I didn't speak Arabic I
would get stuck on one verse and I would
just space out days I'd be on a Prayer
mat and just like trying to figure it
out and when I look at it my phone would
just be blank and darkened I would just
find myself contemplating about what
this book is trying to say to me it was
communicating to me brother Eddie and by
Allah's permission alhamdulillah I was
able to understand that message and
Allah guided my heart in short I know he
said short but that was a very long
response I'm sorry about that so you
went don't put me in a Chokehold on a
journey yeah you went on a journey yeah
and I found this over the years
interviewing people who've come to Islam
submission to the Creator not the
creation this is what Islam means to
submit your will to one and only one God
the same way Jesus yes and I do this
often I stop because you got a lot of
Christians watching or other people of
other faiths and atheists whatever
who've left maybe Christianity become
atheists because they saw a
contradiction in the man-made religions
and whatnot so Islam being for all of
mankind a beautiful complete way of life
life people will go all around the world
and test out all the different religions
and then they'll end up coming to Islam
last because of maybe the stereotypes
misconceptions like you even if you've
been born in a Muslim family thousand
percent you're thinking there's probably
a lot of Muslims out there right now
like almost you know Islam is backwards
definitely so now what happens you
finally come back to Islam so would you
say you let I mean everyone is born on
the fitra you know as a child so would
you say then you end up you I mean I
don't even practice you left oh
definitely with every without and I it
pains me to say this because without
Islam I wouldn't be here I mean it's
only because of Islam and spreading the
Deen of Allah and protecting the Deen of
Allah that I'm even granted such a
blessing opportunity and everything like
that to be with you and amongst the
crowd of such beautiful people mashallah
but
I mean I was in Islam and me like uh
obviously I'm I'm Pakistani by descent
and
um you know Islam was not in my
household I grew up in a very
Troublesome household brother idea and
again this is probably for another time
but just a ton of abuse and just a ton
of just it's just it was just tough you
know but when I came to New York in
September 11th and I looked different
and I'm a 12 year old and I want what
any other 12 year old wants you know and
I'm being treated differently I'm being
looked at differently I'm being spoken
to differently I'm being you know made
fun of differently and being bullied
differently I wanted to get as far as
away as I could from that I mean that's
understandable for anyone but in that
process I got away from my identity
myself who I was because I didn't know
who I was that's a very impressionable
time in my life and I wanted nothing to
do with Islam I wanted nothing to do
with uh my mom because she would even
wear should the traditional means the
Pakistan clothes that looked close
enough to Islam I wanted nothing to do
with that you know I I did my best to
look as Puerto Rican as Dominican as
Mexican as as someone else as I possibly
could I wanted nothing to do with I
wanted to just be myself and you know it
was just a stigma that carried over with
me for a while for a while for a while
until
um I got to college when University and
when I went to University it just got
out of control because I didn't have a
character in building time I didn't have
the foundations of Islam the terbia that
a child should have a child should have
your child should go to Islamic school
and mosque and weekend school or as much
as you could afford as much as you could
do a helicopter program the youth
programs and that's what the dean said
is going to do I'm so excited for that
too and you find the local message and
if the massages are not doing those
programs run those programs now I run a
program in Queens as well too so if
anyone's ever in Queens and watches it
from there pull up we want to save these
children we don't want your child uh the
Mom calling the Imam my child has become
an atheist and left Islam it didn't
happen overnight where were the telltale
signs were you reading the red flags are
you watching what they're doing I'm a
parent you're a parent you know you know
we need to set these programs up uh
preventative measures and proactive and
teacher to be of the children I didn't
have that and I didn't have that the
identity that anchoring identity so I
grew up not knowing who I was and I
wanted to be someone I was not my
prophet and I say this you know with the
most uh you know stuff for Allah but it
was Kanye West that was my if you're in
Chicago you know Kanye West I'm so oh
Kanye that was my that was my messenger
you know Kanye West Kanye West
every word you were idolizing Kanye West
idolizing it's not even the word I
believed I thought I was him I recorded
I loved Kanye West man like his words
were hips on my tongue why do you think
Kanye West right now is wearing a mask
over his head have you seen that oh yeah
I did what do you think is going on with
Kanye you see I think he's about getting
canceled now everybody can I be honest
if I'm being honest about Kanye and I've
made a ton of the offer him as well too
and even when I was like I mean I mean I
mean because it can happen as well too I
mean
um you know not to go into his musical
biography or discography but I've been
listening to him since the original time
and his music has evolved and I was
obsessed with music as any teenager
would and parents out there your
children listen to music you have
someone else preaching to them too and
this is what you don't realize parents
you know like you're giving them the
gospel as they would say you know and
there's someone else giving the gospel
and Kanye was giving me that gospel his
his albums were the books for everyone
not just me but many many children you
know his he would hide behind from even
earlier time look at his ego his
characteristics right he would hide
behind the Persona of looking good and
dressing good but the truth was that he
was just insecure on the inside and he
has even songs talking about it you know
talking about his insecurities how he
can't even go to the ghost she store
without some clean sneakers and stuff
like that because he's so self-conscious
about his image you know now you have an
identity crisis at a young age you're
not given that and he's growing up in
Chicago with so many difficulties right
father always grew up in Chicago
absolutely yes Chicago yes yes South
Side Chicago I'm not mistaken yes his
mom and everything like that too and so
again I know pretty much about it and he
had a Troublesome childhood so again you
know his idols were who the rappers the
dope boys and everything like that
that's on his block you know that he
sees in you know in in South Side
Chicago whatever wherever he's going up
you know he sees that in the culture and
the rap and the music that he listens to
as well so now his second album comes
out he has a little bit more clout and
everything like that he becomes even
more insecure with himself his God
complex starts coming out a little bit
more you know starts shouting out using
his voice a little bit more as well too
but there's no guidance you know there's
no Quran there's no Foundation there's
no remembrance of Allah there's no
Foundation of what a man and is how a
person should be you know which is the
best example in the Prophet Muhammad
and if he you know someone who is
Sincere and I implore and Kanye to
explore this if he's sincere about you
know walking in the path of Jesus Christ
peace and blessing be upon him well then
follow Jesus's path pray like Jesus has
prayed in regarding Yosemite Kanye pray
like him right bow your head to the
ground right call out to the father
alone acknowledge that you can't do
anything about God Almighty himself so
go to those things so third album comes
out more Fame more success you know
height at his career approaching the
Pinnacle of his career still has that
God complexes coming out more to and
then boom his mother passes away
probably the only thing that was keeping
him sane
he has a pornography addiction
people don't know this a lot of people
don't know this but Kanye has a
pornography addiction right or at least
had one I don't know may Allah help him
and there's so many people doing
pornography addictions it's such a
dangerous thing you know it's a scary
thing you know it's it's I mean it'll
help us all get out of those things man
I've been I've overcome those challenges
myself so I know what it's like man but
he has no anchor no parent who was his
anchor you know now his songs start
talking more about things that are of
the Dunya he talks about in his song how
he had a dream he could buy his way to
heaven but he ended up spending it on a
necklace he's chosen the Dunya over the
dean
he's saying it in his lyrics
and I'm growing up with that too so I'm
choosing the Dunya over my Dean as well
too I start dressing nicer start raising
up more chicks and girls and stuff like
that too you know because I'm trying to
be like him trying to dress like him
being fashionable like him and I'm
trying to take his personality because I
don't have a personality of my own right
I'm someone who just follows the trends
and I'm a follower I'm a follower I'm
not
so what happens now his mom passes away
deep spiral depression boom boom boom
boom boom right doesn't get the help he
needs and people who have mental health
issues are approach about the health
issues mental health is a concept that's
coming out now but he had these issues
from before but never got diagnosed or
get help so now you have the traumatic
event of your mother you don't have that
anchor you start going into Dunya more
he starts dating the wrong people this
girl and I don't want to go into this
thing but you know but the thing is this
he's now gone that path he's experienced
the Dunya he's at the height of the
Dunya he's had it all it didn't give him
the happiness still not happy still not
happy yeah has the top number one
selling sneaker in the world brother
Eddie the world people line up for him
in his music he called that a seance
he said at the mall there was a seance
you see when a person dives into the
occult and does the Jinn and shayathin
and magic and goes into those types of
rituals
and they were Godly before and they were
Christian before and they were someone
of spirituality before they come out
different people because now they've
seen the ugly side they seen the
devilish side they've seen the Demonic
side they've seen what they want him to
do they've seen what they said the uni
music needs to be about he had one of
his most vulgar and filthiest albums
ever called My Beautiful Dark Twisted
Fantasy listen to the name of it My
Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy the cover
of that album brother Eddie is him
having sexual relationship with a
shayateen with the Jinn this is Kanye
West this is Kanye West's first his
fourth studio album his fifth studio
album excuse me Kanye is having uh
relationship with the with the Gin with
the police
yes yes a winged animal in a female form
why is he doing that because this is a
part of the ritual occultic thing that
he was into but he's supposed to be a
Christian Christian yes so when you go
down that path for what success more
famous money which he achieved
didn't give him the happiness right so
now you realize you got to come back to
God so later on he goes through an album
calling it Jesus believing he is God now
so you go through this thing you're
deluded your mental health is kicking in
you're not right anymore you're off your
pills you should have been on medication
you needed help your soul is getting
lost that's what they say selling your
soul right he said in the lyric I sold
my soul to the devil he said it
Kanye said I sold my soul to the devil I
know it was a crappy deal but at least
it came with a few toys like a Happy
Meal he sold himself with the Dinia now
you sell yourself with the Dunya you
realize it's not what it was and you
want to come back to Christ and
Christian and all that and now it's a
facade and Allah is making it an example
of you as well too now obviously it's
his test right but the things that he's
been saying is out of control you know
because that thing that he's talking
about and all that bro like you know
like we shouldn't implore any type of
thing she's saying that such and such
person is a good person I support uh you
know not uh like what are you talking
about man you've lost it right so he's
lost it and he has no one like Ferron
right fedon didn't want yes man that's
right of that one believer who was in
the camp of her own who opposed him and
said you know why giving him a
suggestion why do you got to harm
someone because he's saying that he
believes in Allah and worship nothing
but Allah why you got to harm someone
right so he went down this occultic path
unfortunately it's obvious in his music
he comes out of it it wasn't what he
wanted to do that he's realizing it's
all a setup he's off his medications the
mental health all things he's married
into a witch at some degree and you know
I mean and he's doing all this occultic
Masonic practices and all these things
as well too it's not for Allah he
realized it's not what it's meant to be
so guess what happens
he gets out and he's not the same
anymore trauma post-traumatic from what
he's seen the world and now he's
promoting Christianity I think and now
he's saying he's a Hebrew I think and
he's trying to but he has respect for
Islam alhamdulillah but inshallah
we should get Kanye on this show we need
to talk Kanye Kanye needs Islam and I
think I think the perfect example of
someone in which I'm very very proud of
you guys is when you had brother Andrew
Tate mashallah look how Allah guides a
heart you know Andrew Tay I find him to
be one of the more sincerest Brothers
may Allah bless him and increase him and
you know obviously he's Rough Around the
Edges we all are especially in the
beginning imagine any revert who is but
he needs help he needs good surrounding
Brothers he doesn't need Yes Men he
needs people who will check him right we
all do right in the form of a spouse in
the form of a best friend in form of a
buddy and form of the people in the case
that's a good point Andrew Tate needs uh
not yes men but checkmen check uh that's
it you know some people who love him for
you know not just anybody just like you
know good people with wisdom
absolutely wisdom is so important you
know but it's also important for him to
have that type of circle because he's
the type he'll Chuck people himself yeah
and he deserves to be checked we all no
one is immune to and he does say he says
look we should stick to the word of God
we should go ahead and do something you
don't like when people start changing
the religion absolutely he starts
learning more he starts implementing
more leaving off you know a lot of these
vices that's alcohol absolutely look
look once again we've been through the
the worst of it brother we know what it
is you know like it's tough to leave a
lifestyle right and Islam is a lifestyle
and whatever conflicts and contradicts
with Islam it's not going to stick you
know and I think that one thing that
Islam did for me is that after I had
started reading the Quran and came back
to Islam when I would do a quote unquote
sin something Haram before when I did it
I would just do it and I would not feel
guilty but now when I did it it felt
wrong and who knows brother Andrew Tay
is feeling the the wrongs of what he
might do now and may Allah continue to
open his heart I mean look at us we
shouldn't be judging anyone at all Allah
knows what we do behind private doors
and behind private screens you know so
we're not one the wiser and we have no
right to sell over but we can make Dua
for people and we can ask Allah to use
him to help more people and to spread
the Deen and to complete the favor upon
Him upon you brother Eddie upon me upon
everyone out there everyone watching
everyone listening may Allah complete
the favor upon everyone because we need
Allah's Mercy because without it we
won't be successful in this Dunya and we
damn sure will be successful in the
Hereafter so just touching upon Kanye
West he ends up on Alex Jones Show you
heard Alex Jones of course so he's on
the Alex Jones Show and we want Alex
Jones to also get some true exposure to
Islam and I think he needs it too he's
going when he goes collabing you guys
need to yeah uh because he's also going
through some problems with alcohol and
you see these people kind of
deteriorating in front of your eyes but
Islam is the antidote for all of those
problems everything and you're a living
testimony I'm a living testimony and but
why would and brother Alex Jones be
dealing with alcohol and let me say
right he got canceled he got charges
against him he got court case and fees I
mean look may Allah help everyone but I
know people who are going through like
court cases with divorces and may Allah
Grant everyone's marriage to find
goodness and protect us all from divorce
but some people are and they're going
through nasty divorces and they're being
dragged to court they're paying
thousands of dollars brother Eddie
thousands of dollars for a divorce case
you're telling me about a case like that
he didn't come out and plus they're
dragging your name and plus you were at
the height of your thing and this is in
the sea high and advice endowed for
brother Alex Jones that Allah
when he gave to you he was testing you
testing your appreciation testing what
you were going to do with this platform
now when he took it away from you he was
testing you are you going to be grateful
are you going to have a suburb are you
going to turn back to him these are all
ways and opportunities for us to turn
back to Allah but unfortunately shaytan
Satan through his wrist was his Whispers
comes and turns us towards vices to lean
heavier into the pales into the alcohol
I used to take pills may Allah protect
us I know what opioids are like I know
the vibe and the vice and how it feels
to just sink in that lazy boy I know it
feels nice to forget your problems for a
few hours go to sleep wake up deal with
it later on I know what it's like and
Alex Jones is no different as well he's
turning towards the alcohol may Allah
help him may Allah help him and then
eventually your body needs it and craves
it and wants it I'm a school teacher I
told you alhamdulillah this kid's vaping
is a huge epidemic huge amongst Muslims
as well people children youth okay
vaping vaping big problem okay so in
school kids get caught with Vapes I
teach in Middle School in New York they
usually have metal detectors I don't
know if you guys are if that's weird for
you guys but we have metal detectors in
our schools but not in Middle Schools
only in high schools so they're able to
bring the Vape so they would get caught
in the boys bathroom or even the girls
bathroom like girls getting caught
vaping boys getting caught vaping and
all that sort of stuff right and people
are laughing putting on Tick Tock and
all jokes right but then they get in
trouble suspended and all that sort of
stuff but the truth of the matter is
they're physiologically and
biochemically now becoming addicted to
that nicotine and cap and and chemical
in The Vape and the oil and all that
sort of stuff yeah it's funny to do it
in the boy's bathroom when the girls
bathroom but they physically need it
they need it otherwise they're going to
get a headache otherwise they're tapping
the I need a smoke right so they'll go
can I go to the bathroom Mister can I go
to the bathroom
this is the symbol in ASL for bathroom
right yeah write you a patch you go
there for extra three minutes because
take a little vape and then we're
getting uh find out that you're taking
so you know like people have these vices
so Alex Jones you're no different
the alcohol stay away from it may Allah
help you turn bow your head Alex Jones
to the Creator bows ahead to the Creator
turn to him you want a quick number to
dial to the Creator it's called two two
I heard this this amazing amazing um uh
reference right
two sincere tears just tears coming down
from your cheeks right wake up in the
middle of the night 2 am right
you're dealing with problems your
problem's worth it your problem's worth
being solved wake up break your sleep up
for it Allah's testing you how bad you
want it wake up you want to get out that
depression that sadness that anxiety me
wake up break your sleep up two hours
2 p.m 2 A.M in the morning break up
Dodge it wake up fresh will do fresh
will do you know sin's dripping off in
you brother Eddie
2 A.M wake up tuna casts sincerity cry
to Allah two sincere tears badati
tell me that won't lighten your heart
tell me that won't light your heart Alex
Jones I implore you you don't even need
to know the words bow your head the
words will come you will speak from your
heart my brother you'll speak from the
heart alhamdulillah all praise and
thanks is due to Allah the Lord of all
the worlds
he is
merciful to you you don't even worship
him you don't even obey him yet he's
provided for you he's
to you he's a Rahim to you because
you're a Believer you get an extra Mercy
he's a Rahim so brother Alex Jones
you're missing out brother Kanye West
you're missing out you've lost your
minds because you've spent astray the
GPS away from the remembrance of Allah
and when you forget about Allah he
causes you to forget yourself so Kanye
you forgot yourself you put a mask over
yourself because you can't stand to look
in the mirror anymore wow that's deep he
put a mask I mean over his his face we
all wear them so he might as well just
put him on yeah and the excuse somehow
is that and you can't help because you
go to check your email and all this news
is popping up and then you try to see
what's going on so you can go ahead and
give some advice to other people who are
really like you absolutely in a state of
idolizing people like this and they can
see like the dead end that it hits like
it hit with you until you ended up
really turning your life around and
there's other rappers that people are
idolizing there's a Kanye West for
someone else right whether that's for
girls it's the new ice spice wrapper
right uh that you know and the boys want
to be like I have someone like her and
the girls want to be little thoughties
like her right or the the male rappers
who are teaching the boys to disrespect
women and to kill people and do these
dances where they're stabbing their
stomach in the drill music they're
stabbing people and they're making songs
about this brother Eddie right drill
music right over here oh block what are
they saying right killing people music
right
right now right here in in Chicago right
here in Chicago oh block right over here
where they have beef with 63rd Street or
someone whoever it is right a person
King Vaughn getting killed I believe he
was Muslim too may Allah have mercy on
him if that's true right getting killed
they make music about you about your
stabbing yes so there is a new thing and
the fitlins are getting worse because
we're coming towards the end of times
it's in the Disney cartoons with the
lgbts it's everywhere and it's our
responsibility to help the ummah so what
we're doing is that exactly thing so
when our platforms and everything that
we do shake what we hope brother ID is
that we can influence people with my our
children's YouTube channel with me my
daughters if you've ever seen our videos
I don't know if you've ever seen one of
our videos before inshallah we make tawa
videos me and my daughter alhamdulillah
and uh our goal is to just make
family-friendly content that everyone
can enjoy and appreciate you know and to
help the Alex Jones of the world and to
help the Kanye's of the world but to
help that Khadijah of the world get her
Islamic identity you know to help that
Abdullah be proud to say Abdullah and
not Abdul
Abdullah to say Muhammad and Muhammad Mo
I want you to feel proud of your name
proud of who you are proud of being
named Khalid knowing who he is I want to
help by Allah's permission by Allah's
permission just give immense love to
everyone in the world
come together help the ummah to save the
ummah to help build the dean Center to
help build that Center of Norway to help
Allah guide that Quran burner to help
you know guide kanuman whoever whoever
needs the help we're here we're open
Andrew take brother we're here to help
you whatever you need right you were
here to help him whatever he needs we're
here to help anyone stop making
differences stop thinking that there's
Rivals between people stop the YouTube
beef and now Muslims have become Petty I
don't know if you've ever seen that
brother Eddie so many Muslims have
become Petty now putting each other's
names in in the videos like we're
rappers now and you know I'm calling out
such and such person and now they're
gonna make a video about me calling me
out and we're just climbing the ladder
usually using hate and propaganda and
and you know false silly beef and what
is that is that how you want to grow is
that you want how you want to get
subscribers is that is that like a stock
for Allah like no is that we're the form
of the scene when we do that we need to
put our powers together look at this
mashallah I just have to say this I know
you don't like complimenting yourself
and hearing this but you gotta just
please listen
Islam net is not a sponsor of this they
are a organization in Norway yet you had
no problem speaking about them and
saying the good work about them that
shows towards your qualities and
character
and this is why I know the dean Center
will be done because your sincerity is
what impresses me so much
and that's what
excited me when I first started watching
you back in like 2013 or something like
that so just thank you for everything
that you do about Eddie seriously may
Allah reward you and accept from you and
just continue to use you as a South
Korea for this Omar I mean thank you
brother so uh before we wrap up tell us
um you got the zamzam boys what's the
zamzam boys I'm glad you asked me about
Charlotte thank you so much oh sure so
thank you thank you thank you so uh
basically this is a part of our
merchandise line right now uh
alhamdulillah like I want to be someone
who gives back to the um about Allah's
permission and you know a lot of the
videos that people know me for my lost
permission is like you know giving away
an iPad quizzing strangers by Islam for
an iPad or quizzing Muslims buy some for
an iPad right and we have a new video
coming out inshallah uh called uh asking
Medina University students this question
for a Macbook so we're going to give
students of knowledge Medina University
students a brand new Macbook uh so that
they can like learn a little bit
obviously like have a better uh like
technology to use to seek more knowledge
and just to help out and ask them really
cool questions about Islam to test their
knowledge but that requires money
MacBooks are expensive you have a
beautiful set you know how it is so what
happens right now is that I take all a
lot of people don't know this right
because you know they might think oh
YouTubers make money this and that it's
actually not true for example our our
rates are really low because we of the
subject that we talk about right so it's
not like typical YouTuber numbers uh but
the way a lot of us earn is through
brand deals and AdSense but specific
brand deals so what I've done is that I
don't eat I don't take anything brother
Eddie from my brand deal what I do is
that I take that money and recycle it
back into the videos right so
um alhamdulillah I could do that by
Allah's permission he's allowed me to do
that so the thing is that when I get a
sponsorship I put it back into a video
I'm able to buy a Macbook or an iPad or
something like that but it's getting
expensive and the things that we want to
do brother Eddie require a lot more
money right we want to help deal them at
a higher level right so this is one
video inshallah about Allah's permission
refilming it's called Uh knocking on
Muslims doors and paying the rent so
we're gonna go to like a Muslim
predominant area that might be
struggling something like that just
knocking their doors and just pay the
rent and inshallah so that would cost
money so what we're doing is that we're
selling the t-shirts and people can go
to shopsamsungboys.com and order a shirt
when you order a shirt which is pretty
fire like you like it right material is
fantastic it has like a little cool like
you know logo on the side is what's
happening you can see it's very Street
trendy you know great material
um when you order this a hundred percent
of the profits goes back into reinvest
it into the dollar so we get to make
cooler videos you know and more videos
for the Youth and just fun like Masha
Barca level excited me was knowing that
your children love my videos they watch
my videos which is pretty pretty cool
and to know that I have a demographic
that are very very young excites me
mashallah so I want to make videos for
them to help re-establish their Islamic
identity and strengthen their Islamic
identity and I just want to make amazing
videos with no budget you know and I
know by selling this merchandise and by
lost permission by Allah Allah's
permission because he's not shy any
means when you guys buy this merchandise
it will help support the channel which
is what this would do so anyone
interested in the shirt please shout out
to voice.com I'm sure we'll be Link in
the description as well so thank you
brother you're welcome thank you brother
for uh spending some time with us we got
to cover a lot inshallah this can be of
benefit thank you very much and thank
you guys very much and for the Kanye's
The Alex Jones and everybody else out
there from the
person who's uh cleaning the streets to
the person who's a billionaire and you
still on the same Earth and you're
seeking to know the purpose of life and
we talked about we opened up with the
Quran talking about the Quran and the
man who's burning it out there he should
read it you should read it and how
you're going to get it well it's my gift
to you
thedeneeshow.com go to the website pick
up your free copy today we'll get you
that Quran and then go ahead and call us
if you have any questions call us
1-800-662 Islam we can set it up where
you can visit a mosque connect with your
Muslim neighbor and we'll see you next
time until then subscribe if you haven't
already until next time peace be with
you assalamualaikum